hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the drowning simulator if
I seem a little cheerful it's because
I'm not about to be in a few minutes so
this game came out like a year ago to
advertise lifejackets or something you
pointed out I mean it this Yolo wait
some beer Oh everything's gonna be so
good Oh God
one of my biggest fears of like all time
if you seem like my stranded deep videos
is like I hate the ocean I hate the
ocean just in general it's just pure
liquid death as far as the eye can see
no humans should be out there it's
totally illogical yeah oh thanks
if you have time to warn me about it you
could have done something about it oh
god I just I know I feel sick tend to
this to me because they want to see me
go oh yes come back please because I
mean I know what happened when other
people played it like this game Kate
like a year yes please turn right I
don't know why he's coming it's just
part of the story I'll be less of a game
and more just an interactive movie
watching someone dying is just like AI
don't just hate the ocean for like
browning I hate the ocean because
there's things in the ocean there's so
much things in the ocean like I hate
when cameras do that in movies when they
dip below the surface of live like this
is a giant shark there
I'm scrolling as good as I can this
isn't my like my hyper scrolling wheel
here because it did you know drowning
it's the prevention of it is as simply
as moving your middle finger up and down
as fast as you can
just as that's useful for other things
in life that we won't talk about because
it would be totally alright I'm not
already tired of trying you put it out
there I don't know what you're doing why
are you lagging or my kid is my computer
not capable of handling the graphics of
the situation because oh man
it's rendered so realistically in
beautiful whatever engine this game is
made in oh wow it's not working is it
oh there we go oh no I'm not winning oh
good move take off the shoe okay that
was really weighing you down use it like
in space throw the shoe down and you'll
go up okay alright good move I mean I
know the game was like a fuel task
you're just supposed to like the game
ends only when my middle fingers getting
tired oh I can so relate to this kind of
light in the middle of the ocean oh yeah
where you gonna take your pants off I
don't know what you're doing please it's
gotta pinch down on his bottom legs need
to take care of it
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing what are you doing
I don't know you're doing why are you
grabbing your toes is that a French
thing I have no idea if it helps you
find do it go for it I'm going for the
high score not drowning oh and here it's
gonna stutter again great god I'm losing
I'm losing
oh I'm cold
oh that's it Oh because the ocean is
cold
that's right cuz hypothermia strikes
faster than like the drowning and it
makes you weak and it saps your strength
that's what really gets you Oh should I
stop keep going oh whoa what is that
what was that what was that what was
that I don't know what that was things
are stuttering it was dead you saw
something
I saw something I'm trying my best
I was outing I don't know
my scroll wheel isn't there anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ocean wear your life jacket actually
better yet just don't go out in the
ocean hey if you ever hear that I for
any reason go out into the ocean just
all my fans wherever you are in the
world just prepare to dive in form
together to create a floating human raft
and rescue me
because I'll need it and I have like
only four minutes apparently so you
Bruce win fast o mad why did you want me
to do that so anyway if you think you
can beat my high score and drowning
click the link in the description below
scar yourself for life don't remember
any of the monsters that are lurking
below the surface so I thank you
everybody so much for watching hope I
didn't ruin your day if you just so
happen to be watching this on the ocean
let me know and let me know what you
think of this and you probably just be
like yes well you wear your lifejacket
and yes there are monsters beneath the
sea because you're I imagine your old
sea captain pirate there's the Kraken
out in the water and the Sharks they
come to steal my doubloons but as long
as I get with Cthulhu we have no trouble
I don't know what everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
three nerf lungs I mean everyone could
see happier before you are hopefully
this can hide the shadow in my soul huh
huh really good last [ __ ]